negli episodi precedenti di residenti
volevo dire fregare qualcosa è un po il
castello della disney solo che secondo
me non è il castello della vita
che si sta muovendo solo qua per te
ammazzami e allora signori buonasera che
qua c'è qualcuno sicuro che mi accoglie
però in tutto qui c'è l'album di
figurine minchia dragon ball faccio come
se fossi a casa mia bella comunque nel
senso che questo proprio più allegra di
casa mia se proprio vogliamo fare il
pignolo mi dica entrature ti stanno
aspettando
e la madonna in concerto uno straniero
serve anche a lei piace riconoscerla
vedo che lei esigenti vedi tutti tra
brano è la madonna con cui non frega
ma dov'è quello del soffitto si comunque
e divertente il fatto che ho pregato da
seguire meglio di tutti per favore ci
possono marito un metro e venti o
sembrano madonna quando un machete così
si mette a ridere sono cazzi io ve l'ho
detto io ve l'ho detto ti senti bene io
ve l'ho detto io ve lo a detto però nel
dubbio il machete io lo recupereremo
e servito pregare ci si augura tv questi
secondi più di giudizio di quattro di
laporta chiudi la porta va avanti più mi
la porta via le perché 15 sindaco io ce
l'avevo 23 proiettili micidale piatta e
va bene si faceva niente coppa
che male brava brava giovanna ancora uno
è dubbio che questo apl ma elena scusi
elena costa fatica di kakà ricerca brava
brava il fucile cioè altri proiettili
che a me servono pensavo che saremmo
durati molto meno quindi andata anche
bene senti giova elena mi scusi e
cervicale chiavi di sapar usi con la
foto di famiglia all'attivo no comunque
sapevate sta roba e non siete fuggiti e
siete degli idioti e se posso permettere
va bene ea parte degustare del buon vino
ci sono a voi proiettili si tratterà che
avete notato che il primo residenti vaud
dove trovi subito il fucile a pompa
c'è in genere per trovare un fucile a
pompa residenti volo devi passare le
pene dell'inferno
va bene e c'è qualcosa qua se ne hai
bisogno c'è un cacciavite nel
portachiavi esattamente dove sta il
portale reti ma a me a parte e
cacciavite mi interessano avevo le
chiavi sono mila eccole qua chiave
delusione perché c'è un cacciavite con
lo prendo eccolo con si prende non lo so
eccolo qua nice io posso tornare tutti i
vecchi posti e usare cacciavite dove più
mia durata quindi fantastico se non
fosse che stiamo per scappare con il
furgoncino le fiamme si propagano in
fretta è infatti di non muoverci
secondo me non andiamo lontano proprio
la butto lì e ce lo mettiamo un minuto e
mezzo e poi ci dobbiamo rendita cioè
siccome la mappa è questo dobbiamo poi
tornare a piedi dietro indovina indovina
cosa voglio farvi giocare a just enza in
questo momento no
cosa devo fare vieni
questo perché facciamo sfondare qualcosa
no guido io no fantastico ragazzi adesso
vi posso mostrare a cosa è servita la
mia patente
però devo tornare indietro può sfondare
un po di muri qua semmai si può fare ma
è uno manca secondo prima che cicloni la
casa addosso come non detto
come non detto non detto ce l'hai mica
un secchiello a bilancio in cucina
qualcosa di ragazzi questo è un problema
che non quest'anno avuto da fuoco cosa
saliamo a fare usciamo dalla finestra
desoto che poi tra l'altro che poi è
psicosi di sta gente che si arrampica
tradurre che sono proprio al sicuro in
qualsiasi casa e perché basta che entri
nella sua vita che banalmente una
potrebbe entrare la qualsiasi finestra
no quindi non siamo mai al sicuro
a differenza che con gli zombie lo spero
anch'io se se
ecco veloce e feroce veloce veloce
veloce brava
eccola la finestra dove dovrebbero
entrare la vera uscita ma usciamo
consigliati ma che faremo il villaggio
infestata dai mostri e allora buttati
nel fuoco poi anche un triplo carpiato
per quello che vuoi un rifugio sicuro
per dirmi io non posso st costa gente
però ragazze dai ma cosa padre va via
non è lui
numeri più lascia lasciò andare vai vai
va bene va bene ma vi lascia la lascia
la chissenefrega
va bene così ma che le scariche era
tutto a posto hanno vinca il padre
veramente rinsavito così in un attimo
usarlo come scalino non usano come
scalino eccezione come sapevo che
sarebbe finita così sono le gente che vi
devo dire
era era scontato alla cosa
perché lei coria vita cosa dovevo farci
era rincoglionita lasciare la liga
succedendo ancora non hai più le di tali
non si sa se non te ne andare i pugni al
muro popolino già a schiacciare un di
video doloroso pensa tirare pugni sulle
dita che ti mancano potrebbe essere
ancora un problema di qua siamo entrati
siamo stati dieci minuti ed è finita
così
molto bene ma che chiede il mora che può
che cazzo del rumore di milano
[Risate]
ma che cazzo linee la gente in sopposto
chi era madre miranda l'ha detto lui non
so se era chiaro io vado a chiedere mi
scusi mi può ripetere chi è dove sparito
da ecco qua ma non c'è cadavere sparito
padre nella dimora di madre miranda che
vedo che sono molto accoglienti
no perché non dovrei andare via lucia
recchia di prima a vecchia la morte
giunta per tutti loro
anche per me è un piacere di vederti mia
inter ivete qui visto questa cosa c'è da
ridere
non so perché la gente rivisto posto c'è
cosa che facendo ridere si può entrare
in sa dimora senza aver problemi
eccola qua non c'è un'altra via dico
fermi
c'è una porta che ovviamente sarà
chiusissima pro magari con proiettili
robert no non puoi usare questo oggetto
che circonda
una sorta difetto circondato da ali va
bene ma lei ragazzi allora diamo nella
porta corretta che dovrebbe essere
questa che porta direttamente al
giardino del castello marton di adro
anche girare minchia che bordello
bordello nega sia bello c'è una bella
faccia zio vera figata avere come chiavi
di casa sta roba pensando se tornando
dall'esselunga con le buste dei fare sta
cosa dentro anche un casino pro bello
cioè almeno rende un po challenging la
tua vita madre e miranda permesso altro
che sangue e morte è meglio che star la
sfigata di future fogne bellissimo ragab
l accoglienza bene suggerirei di mettere
due aiuole però vabbè quello fate voi
ragazzi mi sembra di giocare d'amnesia
con una grafica power up incredibile
coppa c'è qualcosa
bene bene chi cazzo somma giorno pensavo
non ci fossero sofferto sì ma il
martello io lo svolgere la pentax a chi
cazzo sei tu l'ho già detto io un
forestiero anche meglio
e vabbè
intanto guarda da residenti morselli in
poi offrendo tante di quelle robe lì
come faccio a essere vivo una cosa è
andata meglio di quanto pensassi ti puoi
togliere il palo che mi è ficcato nel
cuore tanto come faccio a treviso basta
lagne
ci siamo quasi roberta è solo ficcato
due o tre ingranaggi nel cervello non fa
niente hanno tutti dei poteri stand
comunque quelli di residenti vaud sono
una figata questa nessuno di voi ha
bisogno di questo amo intrattenersi qui
però questa è una bella sfizio scherzavo
non è una bella notizia
[Musica]
fin da ragazzi e la presentazione di
tutti i bossi diventa di ecco una volta
vuoi passare con lui in privato dove il
divertimento lasciatemelo e creerà uno
spettacolo che piaceranno quelle madre
mar la piccola a chi vuoi che importi
del tuo cerco garantisco che lo muscolo
soffrirà anche come no e poi nel
castello gli tagliate l'uccello bravo
bellissimo bravo devono anche io lo ha
detto rocco siffredi tre ragioni
alcuni di voi sono stati più convincenti
gli altri ma ho preso la mia decisione
a noi lei madre milano la dritta il
destino di quest'uomo è nelle tue mani
minchia heisemberg a un taglio walder
wild eyes è perché sono un ragazzino e
la sua devozione è davvero discutibile
affidate immortale e mi assicurerò che
sia punto io ti ho con la figlia e per
una volta in farà perdere cercati la
cena da un'altra parte conviene stare
zitto e il ragazzino non lascia per la
regnato un ragazzino
sei tu che fai sempre i capricci con
miranda resti responsabilità neanche se
te la parola che sia ancora il lato
desto forse conterrà i tuoi con dichiara
gassino contro l'altra quel signore
la mia decisione definitiva
imparati a stare al vostro papà grazie
ragazzi la situazione è veramente
complicata ma se devo scegliere e orrori
vorrei andare con la tinaia sia per
l'attesa ma niente inizia lo spettacolo
non me lo dare in testa se non ci
vestiamo mittel winters preparati
mi ha liberato 98 76 5
4 veloce e questo tempo un corri corri
mi chiama potevi farlo prima ma donna
legata secondo me i ragazzi era meglio
se mi ammazzava lui va bene niente
lingua ok ma è voi sapevate che ce la
sto molto sotto sotto a casa vostra vero
non sapevate che certo mondo
minchia fu lui che mi mancava in tutto
questo
così succede cosa è successo cosa è
successo non ho capito niente dove cioè
alla fine non riesce mai a ammazzarli
colori non si sa come ai megafoni dentro
la caverna va bene inizia veramente il
confronto saw l'enigmista è una puntata
dei teletubbies devo entrare con dentro
ok l'ho visto subito che c'è una pista
veloce veloce la sera cena perfetto e
stato divertente ma allora è il campino
forte come tipo così si aspetta che
finisce sta roba petrolig ott
come si va da maggio che vado a un forum
sono morto nel momento è lo scudettino
finale
ma io devo fare ma me ne sono accorto
grazie nicchia sarà una battuta non
faceva ridere però mi sono salvato
pensano che sono morto rompe
un'associazione sono accorti che sono
morti con le telecamere di un affitto
russa come cacchio possibile ragazzo c'è
tutto quel 300 lei mi fa anche senza
essere formali poi darmeli così
punizioni pistola cielo ancora la
pistola so tutto
minchia fantarone che la mina antiuomo
va bene sentito qualcuno che ha rotto
qualcosa
salve alle a lui è andata peggio di me
secondo me però andiamo di qua nice
bellissimo posto meno ma la mia forza in
questo gioco e pin germi morto cioè
quando la gente pensa che sia morti nata
poi risorgo la vecchia parte tipo allora
adesso si si si aspettano che sia morto
però non avendo telecamere non lo siamo
calati tua nicchia tutto sto casino e
poi si è tornati qua veramente ok ci
hanno presentato tutti i boss quindi
siamo già a posto
sono tutti uno di britto dell'altro
tranne la milf in bianco quella lì
quella è incredibile andiamo avanti
ragazzi come non so il nome la chiama
così poi si presenterà immagino fa mi
chiamano spaventapasseri facciamo sono
zombie qualcosa non avrò per niente
incubi
ti attendevo con ansia signor winters se
questo come sa il mio nome ma dalla
figura ormai tutti hanno sentito dite
delle tue gesta però in cerca della
propria figlia
minchia questo mi vende le cose tipo
quello di recenti col quattro regali no
vabbè ma ragazzi sto malissimo e
bellissima sta roba
meno male che hanno rimesso il
negoziante era bellissimo avere mercanti
in giro per il mondo risentiva bene rai
o trecento lei non prendo niente e vabbè
puoi prendere anche un fucile va bene le
punizioni ha visto la costano 150 ma
siete pazzi questo costo zero perché
costa zero questo studio ha fame tutto
perché all expansion pack ragazzi perché
ciò delle robe aggiuntive io perché mi
sa che sono quelle ciondola per arma mi
sarebbe web e equipaggio tutto ma che
cazzo ne frega gol in questa ciondolino
personalizzato e anche nel fucile dovrei
averlo eccolo qui bellissimo usiamo
quella nuova e vediamo
credo che me l'abbiamo data perché il
pacchetto espansione non ne sono sicuro
perché non ho letto quando lo comprate
prova beh sale o la dimora
stiamo entrando ragazzi probabilmente
nella nel castello dimitrescu che è
quello della demo perché nella demo che
abbiamo giocato era in un castello qui
non so se vi ricordate lo nelle prigioni
con la parte di non so quando
raggiungeremo e bellissimo raga perché
voi non lo potete sentire ma c'è il
grilletto che adattivo e fa resistenza
condominio e bellissima sta roba 500 lei
la ringrazio quanto viaggi grosso sto
posto si può uscire qua restituisci le
maschere agli angeli e la porta cosa
hanno fatto in tempo a leggere o ci
stanno agli scarafaggi
esatto salve non sono appena entrato per
favore non mi ammazzate fino a un minimo
di accoglienza una tisana bassi tanto mi
hanno fatto le peggio puoi capire
[Risate]
ragazzi questo sarà il mio residenti
vaud è preferito e non mi spiego il
motivo che facciamo madri o catturato
una preda per tim burton e così
premurosissima madre lei da milf la mif
impianto è certo io vediamo fare bene
itanium
e così 6 scampato ai giochetti di
quell'idiota di mitra e lo zio quello
greco che cos'hai di tanto speech e te
lo farei vedere zia però non possiamo
perché già siamo fuori la family
friendly e residenti non possiamo fare
tutto è no no no no no questa non era
nei miei piani sono ottimi potresti fa
oltre si potresti farlo da un'altra
parte che è stato semplice però forse la
sorella ayane potete smetterla di
ficcarmi cosi nelle mani di conosci
fingermi
[Risate]
[Musica]
perché avete ragazzi se notate
dall'inizio del gioco non c'è ogni cosa
che faccio finisce in merda mi hanno
crocifisso istanza non l'ho mai visto
nelle categorie di youtube che male
portanto guarda dopo le due dita perse
chi sarebbero ma come hai fatto
ma non è vero ho perso altre vita no
maledette psi come quest'uomo
incredibili puoi fare tutto non gliene
frega niente lui ne frega niente
bellissimo si si va a perché c'è il
amuchina
se vedo con piacere che si è svestito
già qualcuno qui quindi niente niente di
brutto
no vabbè ma se ci posso dare di mandello
non penso si possa usare i cream under
scassinatore ma dato va bene ma lo posso
riusare che mandello si rompe ok vediamo
no cazzo sei otto ore per caso sia era
ovvio che sono avrei aperto già tutto
quindi impossibile va bene andiamo
avanti interagisci minchia lì sotto si
passa permesso allora teoricamente se mi
ricordo dalla demo stiamo andando nella
zona delle prigioni più o meno perché
era più o meno verso di qua nelle
prigioni ragazzi che adesso magari
raggiunto non lo so perché più o meno la
zona sembra simile anello con l'occhio
rosso sto dicendo nelle prigioni che non
sono queste c'era una porta che sembrava
l'entrata dell'inferno era bellissimo a
vedersi
non mi ci vorrei mai di trovare però poi
quando la troveremo ve lo dirò questa è
la porta che dice che quando la troviamo
ve lo dico stiamo andando esattamente
ciò che hanno portato rosse non lo so
però qua succedono robe stranissima
madonna ma che è possibile che io
raggiungo dei posti mi fanno il culo e
poi irina giungo di nuovo come se niente
fosse
andiamo lì sopra al piano di sopra
questo era il salone che dicevo della
demo finalmente abbiamo raggiunto solo
nella demo ragazzi inizio di pistola ok
ce l'abbiamo fatta finire a questa la
porta chiusa
bellissimo che era questo è racchiuso lo
sbloccato
ok perché succeda di qua scusiamo anche
io che ho fatto il giro fatto il giro va
bene quindi siamo di nuovo qua perfetto
allora questa stanza dovrebbe essere
chiusa come nella demo a punto infatti
andiamo al piano di sopra perché ho già
un anello con l'occhio che se la memoria
non mi inganna
no non è qualche sì questa è la stanza
del vino perfetto per me che sono
astemio è un horror
anche questo questa sia predaia ecco lo
aveva messo l'occhio perfetto ce l'ho
mica che anzi asta porta madonna può
sapere che questo o yes poi avere berger
no no no no per cortesia però non
riuscire ad arrivare già è difficile sto
gioco se le sorelle mi escono dalle
pareti
mi chiamo che schifo
io for corri corri corri non me ne frega
niente delle tue battute da square
l'attrice di uomini tu che cosa
preferisci preferisco che non mi rompi
le palle vieni qua io so già dove
sfondando ma solo perché ho fatto la
demo ragazzi sono non sarei così
convinto ed ecco spiegato come siamo
finiti nelle nella prigione pro quo
c'era ma è tutto il contrario perché da
cui era uscito nella demo invece se ci
sono proprio entrato non c'e neanche più
la scala che roba quindi hanno preso una
location del gioco l'hanno messa al
contrario bellissimo permesso ragazzi
tra un po vedrete la porta di cui parla
tra l'altro ragazzi non c'è bisogno più
di tirare fuori il coltello per romperle
cose le rompe proprio lui con un tasto
apposito seno generoso ufficiale sul
coltello e fare tipo però non è
necessario ecco la porta
se c'è perché l'ultima volta c'era
questa questa è questa questa scena i
ragazzi sta cosa è bellissima
c'è questa cosa e bellissima stanza
incredibile poi c'era una porta mi
ricordo che non c'è più quindi trust in
light che dipende se guardo detto notte
non dovrei proprio lui ha capito devo
portare questo sui cosi eccolo lì anche
nell'altro a preti
inferno madonna è bellissima sta cosa
ragazzo bellissimo
ok è una torcetti na giusto per me
grazie riceve accesa ma come dove ce
l'avevi siamo finalmente entrati nella
parte allegra del gioco greca che da
quasi inizia a divertirsi eccolo qua
questo è una roba sadomaso usano le
sorelle e con gli ospiti
sanremo il giorno l'avevo vista mi scusi
meno male che me ne sono accorto o è qua
siamo arrivati al punto di partenza
della demo quindi abbiamo finito di
citare stacca kg demos va bene c'è
qualcuno che instabile cos'è il demonio
che è successo mi è cascato in un goss
dal soffitto te possino tirare calci in
faccia attenzione che c'è qualcuno lo
sento
raga lo sento vai piano perché c'è
qualcosa qua sarà pieno di licantropi e
roba del genere io li chiamo licantropi
provenne sicuro ha scoperto registrando
tutto il gameplay sicuro dopo tutti nei
commenti mi direte ma non si chiamano
così lo so però che ci devo farmi
sembrano licantropo che vedevo di lupi
mannari e brutto dirlo i sto pagando un
po nelle mutande ma fa niente non mi
esce qualcuno di quasi turano cento cioè
giorno
tornò un attimo indietro che ci ho paura
che cresca altra gente venga qua chimica
è lei non è un licantropo
quanto dura miss e mister no dove vai
c'è una spada quello di un assembramento
ragazzino assembramento è solo
incastrato sono morti così sana pianta
tour e la donna non ci mette troppo a
ricaricare zio e morte morte morte morte
morte cranio cristallizzato è certo se
non volevo non volevo altro da voi
ragazzi sono un cranio cristallizza sono
morti tutti è andata meglio del previsto
devo ricordarmi con proiettili solo per
una persona e ragazzi e sono qua fisco
malissimo
sì che sandra ti avesse ucciso su
picasso
no no no no no no no no no scherzavo
abbiamo d'altra parte non si può andare
d'altra parte merda merda merda meta
nella natura finalmente si è il compasso
questo momento possano uscirne perché
esci giorno meno avremmo scritto ha
spinto lei e me ne ero accorto infatti
monteleone che spara di prima
minchia la finestra la finestra le fa
qualcosa quanto pare non ha fatto niente
s'è spaccata la scuola finestra siete
qua ai a porta lontano
e va beh quello fatto tolti solo fare
facevo il giro volevo andar ragazzi lo
capisco niente dove devo andare
ma se tipo faccio così
devo fare così per forza ragazza che in
un modo o è morta è morta con seccata
raga però mi sono bloccato qui ok è
andata via l'ha uccisa
hanno quindi si può uccidere io non la
scuola va appunto perché pensavo che
fosse inutile invece si può uccidere e
che minchia sono stata una vita senza
far niente mi chiama dillo che la possa
ammazzare no che palle
dunque è da una vita e mezza che non
salvo è una serratura faceva scassinare
il nord di mandello prenoti bocca nel
senso che stai zitto proprio posso
salvare la partita che se so dove sono
non so dove sono meno male che so dove
sono questo la dice lunga
sblocca la serratura vagoni proprio loro
e anche giulia definisce l'episodio di
residenti volo supermamma miei problemi
soffrono i brividi mamma è forse uno dei
residenti voi più belli ma soprattutto
anche perché c'è quella cioè quella tipa
cioè la bio bianco è certo che sta in 3d
stagione incredibile come al solito si
vede vicino il momento non mi piace
anche vari social che come tradizione se
non siete iscritti e noi come sempre ci
vediamo
[Musica]